hey guys it's Joanna here or if only you
could smell my kitchen right now it's
filled with a sweet aroma of
pancakes this February 17 is pancake day
now here's a fun fact
packing day is the day before Ash
Wednesday which is also the final day
before the comments of let for the
Christians Lent is a time of abstinence
so Pancake Day is in fact the final day
to indulge and use up all the foods
which are analog in length for instance
butter fat and eggs which is why
pancakes are eaten because they contain
all those ingredients some call this day
Fat Tuesday so instead of making
traditional pancakes which can be loaded
in fat and sugar I'm going to share with
you three healthy packing variations
which are very nutritious and good for
your body
so let's start by making me hearty of
your pancakes we all know that oats are
extremely good for our body it is high
in fiber protein and low in fat so
consuming all your every morning can
help to keep you satisfied for much
longer and you can also have to reduce
bad cholesterol levels this plate of
pancakes is perfect for breakfast and it
is also suitable for vegans what you
need are 1 cup of oat flour 1 cup of any
milk of your choice or water 1 teaspoon
of vanilla extract 1 teaspoon of maple
syrup or honey 1/2 a teaspoon of baking
powder and a pinch of salt to make the
oat flour place rowboats in a food
processor or blender and pulse until
coarse flour line texture is achieved
mix in the dry ingredients baking powder
and a pinch of salt blend the
ingredients together in a separate bowl
combine the wet ingredients milk maple
syrup and vanilla extract then combine
the wet and dry mixtures mix well to
make the pancake batter in factor is
slightly too dry then add in an
additional quarter cup of water next
coat a nonstick pan with a little bit of
butter or cooking spray over medium low
heat measure about what about that
of each pancake and cook for about two
minutes until bubbles begin to fall flip
when the underside is slightly golden
and cook for another one to two minutes
and to go to brown this will make about
six medium sized pancakes I've lived my
pancakes with sliced strawberries grapes
and blueberries served with a side of
maple syrup just to keep my morning
extra sweet this kind of breakfast will
keep your tummy happy it will put a
smile on your face and set you up for a
good day ahead know if you want to wake
up really quick delicious high-protein
breakfast or snack in under 15 minutes
then this next two ingredient pancake
recipe is for you you only need one
large overripe banana and two large eggs
place banana and eggs into a blender and
blend it up to make the pancake batter
just like the first recipe cook the
pancakes and the medium low heat using a
nonstick pan a very gentle
pancake as it is very light and thing
this will make about a thin and fluffy
medium sized pancakes I've chopped mine
up with banana slices trio of mixed
seeds and dry fruits and drizzle with a
little bit of maple syrup if you want to
pick up this recipe you can even add
ground spices flax seeds chia seeds or
even dried fruits in your mixture so be
creative and create your own flavors and
finally my favorite savory pancakes
which are perfect to be served as your
lunch or dinner these fluffy healthy
sweet potato pancakes are laced with
hearty codes and warming spices what
you'll need are one cup of sweet potato
puree one cup of oats flour two large
eggs beaten Biggins you may omit the
eggs or replace with half a cup of
mashed banana half a cup of any milk of
your choice or water 1 teaspoon of maple
syrup or honey one teaspoon of vanilla
extract 1/2 a teaspoon of mixed spice
1/2 a teaspoon of baking powder and a
pinch of salt in a bowl mix all the wet
ingredients sweet potato puree milk
maimie syrup vanilla extract and beaten
eggs combined well in a separate bowl
mix all the dry ingredients
oats flour baking powder salt and spices
combine the wet and dry mixtures makes
well if batter is too thick then add in
quarter cup of water just like the two
recipes before cook the pancakes
and the medium low heat using a nonstick
pan now do take note that these pancakes
are denser than the typical pancakes and
these would not bother as much on the
bottom like a normal pancakes so you
won't have to peek underneath t check
how they are doing this will make about
a million sized pancakes make this a
main meal and top it up with whatever
you like
I lived mine with cucumbers and smooth
salmon sprinkled with a little bit of
Parmesan cheese
this is also my ultimate post-workout
meal now here's a very important tip to
remember to make fluffy pancakes it is
very important to not press your pancake
while it's cooking in the pan because
that would basically release the egg
instead be patient and just allow your
pancake to cook and to bubble on one
side then just flip lettuce it and cook
until golden brown I love pancakes I
mean who doesn't
whether you prefer sweet or savory be
sure to try these recipes and share your
creation with me on Facebook and
Instagram all the best for new Fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my You Tube
channel and website do follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you